bring it up all the way you guys have  never seen a truck like this before dad  you can't keep spending money on junk I  don't think it's a truck at all I think  we just found a transformer  shouldn't have came after my family  we're the first movie actually shoot  with the imax 3d and imax 3d is really  the way the movie was meant to be seen  sixty percent opens up on the big I max  screen everybody stick behind me when  you think about all the effects of the  3d work and the camera work by Michael  Bay the ultimate experience is seeing it  in imax 3d absolutely incredible this  film is much bigger and scale and in  spectacle than the others and I think  audiences certainly need to experience  in lms 3d cinema has so much hardening  and the imax is you feel like you're on  a ride it's incredible  I think you've got to experience it in  imax to understand how cool it is  you